pancham overcome is great a spirit and
so much fun to watch
I am overcoming some of my fears today
with the Irwin family who are bringing
some very scary yet adorable
apparently species oh no no really for
real for real yeah that didn't make me
feel too confident about what I was
getting into how sweet is this Diamond
Python so actually he's a different
adjective probably I'm gonna take his
little head soft
oh he's grabbing on now can you see he's
just gonna wrap around just to hold on
to you like you're a tree how quickly
can we get an ambulance here
it's no wonder bindi is so comfortable
she's been handling snakes her whole
life she even got her first snake bite
at only 18 months old so she was ready
but I wasn't for what came next so the
next snake one of his menu items has
other snakes so since you smell like a
snake now we have to kind of wash up
before we play with it today I'm
thinking otherwise you might try to
could we have started with that night
maybe
that snake five foot indigo Python I
look comfortable right now
yeah do I look like I'm pretty confident
well X okay yeah it's preparing I
thought you've never eaten a single pass
a night we have okay I was feeling
pretty good then I saw this what words
how are they yeah okay okay slow read uh
national movements he looks happy and
angry a 14-foot albino reticulated
python named lemon she's the same exact
snake bindi dance with on Dancing with
the Stars say this is a snake big enough
to eat a person yes okay she is a sweet
hopper to be the longest snake in the
world
okay well that's nice and everything but
is she hungry she's shedding her skin
yeah so she's just about done shedding
so she'll she'll need you know something
the size of a small goat what she's done
Shetty hey boy she's warning me she's
going to my conscience she's fine what
is she doing down there really fine okay
famous they've got um her forked tongue
action senses heat so she knows please
God you get more what's happening I felt
what's happening you're praying you're
totally high see that's a good slightly
fine God answers why I swear so badly
but I'm not going to
note to self never do this again
the only thing I have to say is that cam
can good okay oh god I got a damn I
thought you're a little more like a you
know well I got listen it's a natural
phobia I can't do anything about it and
I thought of this after I should have
been wearing a heartrate monitor so you
guys could have seen just how my heart
was busting out of my chest it was out
of control
Evan adorable